- In San Francisco,
as we move towards project based learning
on some of our subjects,
science lending itself most readily to it.
We embedded the Five E
architecture to the curriculum,
which gave it a much more bite-size feel.
We knew that what we
needed was a through line
through the curriculum that the students
would start to recognize
and start to build upon.
- We really think that the
Five E instruction model
matches the needs of our students,
that it really elevates
the importance of learning
for some of our English language learners.
It makes things more digestible
for students across the board.
All of the learning that's happening,
is happening in subunits that go
from the engaged through the evaluate.
- So, the first E is the engage.
Students are given a certain phenomenon
that they might not know about.
They get to be immersed in that thing.
You're gonna get a set of cards
that has a whole bunch
of information on it.
And you have to sort through
whether that's climate or weather.
But you gotta do it as a group.
After that is the explore.
Students get to experiment.
They get to use and
utilize different tools
to try to investigate the thing
that they were checking out in the engage.
Would anyone like to read the explore?
- In the previous lesson,
you thought about your
personal carbon footprint.
Today, you will analyze data
about the carbon footprint
of the school that students--
- That gives the students a lot of like
hands on activities and experiences
with a particular phenomenon.
After that is the explain.
With the explain, students really focus on
a lot of the literacy
pieces of the science.
This one's gonna require
you to do a little bit of,
of processing of the information
that you've already gathered.
They get to exchange information.
They get to extract
information from each other.
After that, you have the elaborate,
which they then take what
they learned from the engage,
the explore, and then explain,
and they elaborate on that.
And after that, is the evaluate.
That lets us as the teachers
know where they're at.
Whether they're understanding it.
Whether they're not.
What about you guys?
Do you guys see that as well?
- When we embedded the five
E's in this curriculum,
what we found is as a
byproduct is that the teachers,
as they provide us feedback,
they are very specific
about did it actually
engage the students in
the way that we wanted to.
Did the students explore the topic
in the way that they wanted to?
Did the evaluation of work
actually show that the students
were accessing grade level work?
- With the Five E instructional model,
we're seeing more students
getting their hands wet.
We're seeing more
students contribute ideas.
We're seeing more students participate
in many different ways.
(children chattering loudly)